stop let me go really really wrong yeah
well here we are three years later and
the cast of The Fresh Prince of bel-air
just reunited for the first time ever
for Will Smith's snap chat show will
from home how's everybody doing how
often do we even pop on a call and say
hey how you doing it's actually the
first time part one of the two-part
finale premiered on Wednesday now we're
breaking down five things we learned
from their chat became the Prince of a
town called bel-air number five on our
list wills acting I suck so bad as an
actor yeah he's definitely an a-list
actor now but he says back then his
acting skills needed work the bore
whizzes in Quincy were like no we need
to surround him with the best of the
best and all of you guys are
professional actors
yeah then there was this you remember in
the pilot episode and I did the whole
life daddy dollars thing and when I
spoke to you and you had memorized
everything yes dad I need $300 not only
did we'll learn his own lines
he learned everyone else's too I was
learning
everybody's lines cuz I was doing this
she pulled me aside she's like hey what
the
oh and get this
it was wills castmate alfonso ribeiro
who convinced will to name his character
in the show well Will Smith do you
remember it so the reason that my
character's name is Will Smith is
because of you do you remember that I do
I do I remember cuz like we had talked
and I said look if you're ever gonna do
this show you've gotta be will Smith it
was such a deep insight that you've you
had you say because people are going to
call you that for the rest of your life
next up the cast chatted about how they
dealt with people knowing them as their
characters from the show out in the real
world any of you have a problem feeling
stuck in the world and expecting you to
be your character got really really
annoyed that everybody wanted to do the
handshake I'm not so secret handshake
that was subject oh you know the
handshake and you know you'd try it too
let's leave it to the pros you would see
in people's eyes when they were about to
sneak the handshake and I would just
grab their hand and hold him oh I'm good
and last but not least Tatyana Ali
revealed that will was a big part of the
reason she went to college you being
educated on The Fresh Prince and then
getting accepted into Harvard oh yeah
not just any college Harvard people
Harvard was just a magnificent
accomplishment cuz you know I never went
to college so that was up going to
college was up a huge value to me always
felt lesser than when I got accepted to
Harvard I was doing music absolutely I
saw the world through music because of
you because you believed
me when it was time for me to go inward
which for me that was going to Harvard
who sat at a table with me being the
person who invested in me and Tomi I
should bow will thank you thank you for
giving people the reunion they want will
has told et a lot over the years that
fans shouldn't expect a reboot hmm or at
least not one starring the og Fresh
Prince I'm not doing it so I mean I
guess if somebody wanted to I would
probably let them but you know I have no
intention look I'd like a proper reboot
but I'll take what I can get